from mit and he'll be telling us
in his lecture series about recent
advances in high dimensional learning
kicking it off today with tensor
decompositions so
okay great so thanks everyone for coming
and thanks for the invitation to speak
so in the first part of this tutorial
i'd like to give you an introduction to
one of the most important methods in
high dimensional parameter learning
these are tensor decomposition so i'll
walk you through
what tensors are what tensor
decompositions do
and what problems they solve that
ordinary matrix decomposition
alone wouldn't do the job and i'll talk
about some candidate applications
so let's get started so in fact
the story for tensor decompositions
really starts way back when
it starts from the origins of factor
analysis so
in case you don't know factor analysis
started in psychology with some
pioneering work of charles spearman back
in the
early 1900s and he had a simple
hypothesis that's now called spearmint
hypothesis
he believed that fundamentally there
were two types of intelligence
inductive and reproductive so what these
mean are that inductive is the ability
to make
sense out of complexity and reproductive
is the ability to store
and reproduce information so this was
just the hypothesis so how would you go
about testing
such a hypothesis well here's the
experiment that he devised
so he took a thousand students and ten
different tests that they'd taken
and he recorded how well each student
did on each test so each row represents
a test from a different subject and each
column represents a student
and then actually in order to test this
theory he invented what's now called
factor analysis
so roughly what he believed was that
there was some
knife factorization of this matrix m
this 10 by a thousand matrix that he
observed
into the product of two other matrices a
times b
transpose and what's important in here
is actually the inner dimension
in this factorization so he believed
that
there was some way to approximately
represent the matrix
m as the product of two matrices
where a is a ten by two matrix and
b transpose is a two by one thousand
matrix
and in fact what he believed was that
the columns of
a would represent something about which
types of tests tested what elements of
adductive
versus reproductive reasoning and each
column and b
transpose represents the aptitude of the
student
in inductive versus reproductive
reasoning
so this is a hypothesis that you can try
to test out we found some
results that seem to support his
conclusion in fact in psychology
people have continued to study this and
they've created a hierarchy of different
notions of intelligence and how they
relate
through things like factor analysis but
in fact if we think about this
mathematically and as a learning problem
then something is a little bit strange
about
trying to find some unknown
factorization
that you think has a nice explanation
just from
a matrix of data because what he's
really hoping
is that maybe this matrix m if there
were no noise
you could write it as a times b
transpose
and here i've written it as summation
over i of ai
tensor bi transpose so the ais are the
columns of capital a
and the bis are the columns of capital b
and basically the question we're asking
is one of identifiability
so even if spearman was right and even
if there was no noise and we could
observe this matrix
m perfectly and there was indeed some
nice
explanation of m as a product of a times
b
transpose well one question you can ask
is can we actually find
this nice factorization uniquely and
actually there's a major
major problem with trying to do factor
analysis with just
matrices which is that even if there is
a
true factorization that's nice out there
that lends itself to being
interpreted very easily well you could
take that factorization you take
any invertible matrix r and you could
put
r times r inverse in between a and b
transpose
and then when you group a times r
together and r inverse times b transpose
together
you get another perfectly valid
alternative factorization
and the trouble is that that
factorization is something that you
might discover when you compute matrix
decompositions on
m so even though there is a nice
explanation for m
in terms of factor analysis you can't
necessarily recover it uniquely
in fact what i claim is that the answer
to this question about when you can
recover the factors a sub i and b sub i
uniquely
is actually not very interesting you
need very very strong conditions
on these factors in order to determine
them just from
m in fact what you need are things like
the a and base of i and b sub i being
orthogonal
or you need that the rank of the matrix
m is one
and these are actually the only
conditions under which you can recover
these factors uniquely
from a matrix so this in factor analysis
is a major problem it's called the
rotation problem
you can take a valid factorization that
you wanted to find and you can rotate it
and that might be the factorization you
find something that's not readily
interpretable
so this is the way that i like to think
about tensor methods is that
at their core they're a way to solve the
rotation problem
because tensor methods which i'm going
to introduce in the next few slides
are things which are going to have
unique decompositions under
much tamer conditions that's why
people in diverse areas like
psychometrics cared about them for many
decades
but that's also why they show up in
modern high dimensional machine learning
problems
especially ones in which you want
provable guarantees
so now that i introduce the rotation
problem i want to tell you about
something called generics algorithm
so first we have the notion of a matrix
decomposition that i've described before
is
you can think about a traditional matrix
decomposition as writing m
as the sum of capital r rank 1 matrices
each one of these rank one matrices is
an outer product between an a sub i and
a b sub i
well tensor decompositions look
basically the same
you start off with a tensor which now
instead of a two by two grid of numbers
is a instead of a two dimensional grid
of numbers it's a three-dimensional grid
of numbers
so you index into t with three entries
i j and k those are the indices and the
important thing is that you want to
write
the tensor of data as a low rank
decomposition
and here what's the notion of a rank one
tensor well if you give me
a vector x a vector y and a vector z you
can similarly define their tensor
product
and the entry in the i j k location of
the rank 1 tensor
x tensor y tensor z is the i f entry of
x
times the j entry of y times the ks
entry of z
so it's something that has this nice
product structure and when you have a
tensor what you want to do is you want
to write it as the sum of not too many
rank one tensors that's what a tensor
decomposition is
so now back to the original question
about factor analysis which
i claim you know one of the main reasons
to care about tensor decomposition is
the answer to the following question
so let's study when are tensor
decompositions
unique and there's a beautiful theorem
of generic in 1970 which says that
suppose that the a sub i's and the b sub
i's
are linearly independent and no pair of
vectors
in c sub i is a scalar multiple of each
other
then what you can do is if you have a
tensor which is the
sum of not too many rank 1 terms where
each rank 1 term looks like
ai tensor bi tensor ci then what i claim
is that that tensor decomposition
is unique so the uniqueness conditions
we need are that the a sub i's are
linearly independent the b sub is are
linearly independent
and something on the c sub is that's
even a little bit weaker than linear
independence
now uniqueness is a little bit subtle
because you have to define it properly
you can never tell which of the rank one
tensors in this decomposition
is the first one which one's the second
one so really what we mean is that
it's unique up to permuting the rank one
terms in this decomposition
and this also means that you can do
things like you could rescale a sub i
by some factor like 10 provided that you
rescale
b sub i by 1 over 10 or c sub i by
something else
so the overall scaling in front of the
rank one term
doesn't change so this is a beautiful
result of generic from the from 1970
and actually i have to confess that um
this result
was not really understood this result
got rediscovered
um at least that half a dozen times
maybe more at this point
by many different communities so it's
actually kind of interesting i remember
when i first started teaching a graduate
course
in high dimensional machine learning i
didn't even know about generics
algorithm i had some earlier reference
that i thought was the original one that
solved the tensor decomposition problem
and then i realized that it actually
wasn't the first um
you know place where tensor
decompositions had been defined
and so i i did a bunch of reading to try
and find this in fact this result of
generic actually appears in a paper of
harshman
back in the 1970s and i think um yeah
it's been rediscovered at least you know
six to ten times
and one of the beautiful things about
generic's
theorem is that it turns out that it's
actually an algorithm too
so sociologically this is actually one
of the reasons why it got rediscovered
so many times
because in the psychometrics community
they had generics results
and then a few years later they had an
even stronger uniqueness theorem
called kruskal's theorem that turned out
to not come
with an algorithm and afterwards in the
psychometric speak community people
forgot about the fact
that generic uniqueness theorem actually
came with an algorithm and they only
knew about kruskal
and that was actually one of the reasons
why so many other communities seemed to
rediscover this
was they all invented different
algorithms but i'll show you the
original one today
so now the first thing that i want to do
in this talk is i want to explain
generic algorithm
it's beautifully simple and it just
relies on the notion of eigen
decomposition
and some simple operations that you can
perform on
tensors so generic algorithm is a great
way to get a feel for
how exactly you can work with tensors
and then the later parts in this talk
i'll explain how exactly tensors come up
in a high dimensional learning problems
so in fact tensors are very hard to work
with most questions that you ask about
tensors like
you know computing their rank or
computationally hard
so the trick behind generic's algorithm
is to reduce it to a problem about
matrices but it does it in a very
delicate and
interesting way so imagine that we have
this third order tensor in its
third order because it's a
three-dimensional grid of numbers
and one thing we can do is we can try
and flatten it by adding up different
matrix slices
so when i take this tensor t and i plug
in a vector x
what i want to do is i want to add up
the different
slices through t and i want to multiply
each one of those slices by the scalar x
sub i
so when i do it this way when i hit the
tensor t with this vector x i end up
with a matrix so if the original tensor
was m
by n by n x is an n dimensional vector
and when i compute
t of dot coma dot comma x i get an n by
n matrix that's defined through this
formula
that's the first step in generic's
algorithm
and the important thing to think about
what's going on here and this will play
a crucial role in
understanding why generic's algorithm
works is you should keep in mind just
thinking about the world's simplest
tensor when you're first seeing this
algorithm
think about a tensor that's rank one so
what if the tensor that i was given were
a
tensor b tensor c then what happens when
you hit the
tensor with this vector x what you're
going to get is again going to be a
matrix but in fact what's really nice is
that it's a rank
1 matrix in fact you can express it in
terms of a b
and c you get a scalar which is the
inner product between c
and x and then you get a rank one matrix
which is a
tensor b so that's the key thing
so in fact we don't know this underlying
tensor decomposition for t that's the
thing that we'd like to compute
but we can express what doing this
operation of hitting it with the vector
x
does to that decomposition that we want
to find
because this operation is linear all it
does is that same
operation on each of the rank 1 pieces
so you get the sum over
i of the inner product between ci and x
that's a scalar
times ai tensor bi so if you start off
with a rank r
tensor this operation of hitting it with
a vector x
produces a matrix whose rank is at most
r
as well and here you should think about
x as being chosen uniformly at random
from the unit 2.
so now uh the way that i can think about
this is that i can take
i can express it as the product of three
matrices so i can think about
a times dx times b transpose where dx
is a diagonal matrix whose entries along
the diagonal
are the different inner products between
c sub i and this vector x
and then i could do the same thing again
with another vector y
so i chose y uniformly at random when i
flatten the tensor according to y
i get a times d y times b transpose it
looks almost the same
the only difference is that the diagonal
matrix has changed depending on
what vector i use to flatten it and now
here's the key idea in generic's
algorithm so what if i take these two
flattenings one corresponding to x
and one corresponding to y and then i
create
some new matrix that looks like the
flattening i get from x
times the inverse of the flattening that
i get what
now just to keep things simple i'm going
to assume that all of these matrices
are invertible but really when they're
not invertible what you would do is
you'd use the pseudo inverse instead
that's not a major complication but it
just means that i have to use pseudo
inverses so
let's keep it simple and let's assume
they're invertible
now the key thing is that i can express
what this matrix t of x times
t of y inverse looks like in terms of
the factors that i want to find
and so if i just write down what that
expression is it's a
times dx times b transpose times b
transpose inverse times d y inverse
times a inverse so now the b transpose
cancels
with the b transpose inverse and i get
something really nice which is a
times a diagonal matrix times a inverse
and this
is the aha moment because you know when
i only give you access to t
you can compute t of x you can compute t
of y
and you can compute this t of x times
the inverse of t of y
that matrix that you've constructed from
your data
now has a simple diagonalization because
what this really is
is it's an eigen decomposition so if i
can compute the eigen decomposition
of this matrix that i've constructed in
the third step
then it's actually going to reveal some
of the factors that i wanted to learn
because i'm going to learn a as the
matrix that i need to diagonalize that
matrix that i've constructed
and so the key claim is that you know if
your factor c
sub i had the property that no two of
them were scalar multiples of each other
then you can check that you know when
you compute these flattenings t of x
times t of y and create this new matrix
that actually this eigen decomposition
will not only be an identity composition
but it will actually be
unique and that's what guarantees you to
actually find
the true a that you wanted to find
so that's only part of the factors
because i still need to find the columns
of b
and i still need to find the columns of
c so what do i do after that well i can
diagonalize
a matrix that's the other way around i
take t of y times the inverse of t of x
and that's going to have another nice
expression in which
the thing which diagonalizes it is b
and when you've learned all of the
factors a sub i and b sub i
it turns out that you can match them up
because the eigenvalues that these
eigenvectors correspond to they turn out
to be reciprocals of one another
and then there's a way once you know the
a sub i's and b sub i's
well the only unknowns you're left with
are the c sub eyes
so you can just solve the linear system
to recover them
so this was generic's algorithm it's
amazing that he came up with this way
back when in the 1970s
and it's something which was actually
done within the psychometrics community
and even though they didn't have the
language of algorithms because this
actually predates a lot of theoretical
computer science they still had very
interesting algorithms in this
literature
so now let's go back to our rotation
problem so the real problem with matrix
decompositions as i mentioned
was that the factors a sub i and b sub i
are not uniquely determined when all you
know is the matrix
but what happens if you give me a low
rank tensor
where t is the sum over i is a i tensor
bi
tensor ci well we can ask the same
question which is when can we find the
factors a sub i and b sub i
uniquely and the answer now is much
broader we need a much
less restrictive assumption on the
factors in order to be able to do this
because what generics algorithm tells us
is that we can uniquely recover these
factors
up to some naive rescalings provided
that the a sub i's and b sub i's are
full rank
and that no pair of vectors and the c
sub i's are scalar multiples
of each other so this very simple
algorithm turns out to be immensely
powerful within high dimensional
learning
and high dimensional statistics
so now that i've introduced the rotation
problem
and generics algorithm let's have some
fun with some applications
so really what generix algorithm is good
for is it lets you solve
all kinds of learning problems in latent
variable models
let me explain some actual applications
so we can get a feel about
when we can apply generics algorithm and
what kind of structure in our
probabilistic models is conducive
to being able to use tensor methods in
the first place
so let me tell you one which i think is
another beautiful story
it's about phylogenetic reconstruction
so here in phylogenetic reconstruction
we have this notion of different species
and how they evolved from each other
and just to introduce some terminology
we have
some species that are currently living
today these are called extant
species these are the red circles and we
have some species that
are now extinct and these are the green
circles
and basically what we believe is that
there's a tree of life about that
explains
how the different species evolved from
each other
and how those relate the species that
are now extinct that only existed
in the past now one of the basic goals
in phylogenetic reconstruction
is we have access to genetic sequences
from modern
living species all of these extant
species
and we want to stitch together that
information as a way to piece together
what this tree of life
looks like so that's the basic inference
task in phylogenetic reconstruction
is that you have genetic information and
you'd like to find this
underlying generative model that
explains how your data was constructed
now for those of you who care about the
applications let me say a few words
really what you assume
is that for all of the living species
that you've already solved the very
challenging task
of aligning their sequences so when you
think about having all of these
different species and you've aligned
their sequences
you think about looking at the jf
coordinate into
this vector of base pairs that describes
you know which the order of base pairs
in each of their gene sequences and you
think about that as being a sample from
your model
because each one of these species well
it'll have a symbol
at that particular genetic location in
its dna
it could be something like a c t or g or
it could be something even more
complicated depending on how you set it
up
but the way that this works in terms of
the stochastic model
is that you assume that there's some
alphabet sigma and this could be
you know a size 4 alphabet like a c t
and g
it could be something bigger like you
know the set of all proteins
you get to pick it but what you assume
is that
there's some underlying distribution on
the root
so you first choose what symbol is
assigned to the root
and then what you do is there are a
bunch of transition matrices that
describes
how the symbol for a parent affects the
distribution for the symbol of its child
so this matrix r z b describes
you know if you it's a um if the
alphabet is size k it's a k
by k matrix and one of the rows in it
describes well
if this hidden node z has a particular
symbol in the alphabet
what is the conditional distribution on
what symbol
is assigned to its child namely the
species that's described by the
so this is a model that describes the
transmission and things like mutation
along this tree of life
and the question is well can we actually
reconstruct
underlined tree and these transition
matrices that describe these conditional
distributions
when all we get to do is push a button
and get a sample
and each sample here just to be precise
is really just a vector of symbols
the length of the vector represents the
number of extant species
and that vector just describes which
symbol we observe at each of the
different leaf nodes in the stream
actually there are related problems that
fit exactly into this framework too for
those of you who are more familiar with
you know things like signal processing
and speech recognition
well a very specialized case of this is
already the hidden markov model
which you can think about as being a
situation in which
the tree structure that describes your
generative model is very simple
because it's just this caterpillar graph
there's just
a line on these hidden nodes which
represent hidden states
in your system and what happens is that
at each node you have a hidden symbol
that you don't observe and then you have
some matrix
so first you choose an initial
distribution on the first state
which just when you push the button
chooses what symbol you assign to the
starting state
x and then you look at these observed
matrices
observation matrices that describe for
each hidden state
what is the distribution on the symbols
that you observe
at that time step and then there's a
bunch of transition matrices that
describe
well once you tell me the state at x
how does that affect the distribution on
the state at what
so this is what a hidden markov model is
it's just a special case of one of these
phylogenetic tree models
where you have a very simple underlying
tree
and so we can ask this question in the
context of solid genetic reconstruction
which is a deep and beautiful
question that connects to a lot of
mathematical biology and statistics
which is can we reconstruct the topology
from
random samples
so usually what you do is you assume
that the
all of these transition matrices in the
phylogenetic model
are full rank so that you can re-route
the tree arbitrarily however you want
and then it turns out that if you think
about it
different nodes which are observed well
the further nodes are apart from each
other the closer and closer to being
independent they ought to be because you
have to go along a long path to get from
you know x to y so it turns out that
you can actually make this intuition
precise and that there's actually a
distance function
along the edges that if you told me the
transition probabilities
the transition matrices and you told me
the underlying tree topology
there is this crazy expression right
here that describes a distance function
between pairs of edges and the key thing
is that you can actually
estimate this distance between pairs of
leaves
and the distance between leaves turns
out to be the sum of distances
along the paths in the tree this was
completely a non-obvious result
it's a beautiful result of steel from
the mid 90s
because the way that i've described it
right now it's not even
obvious that the thing is non-negative
to begin with
so it turns out what you can do is you
can just use steel's distance function
to reconstruct the topology of the tree
because imagine that i have four
different leaves a
b c and d well you can think about how
to connect
all of these four different leads with
pads to each other through the tree
and you can convince yourself that there
are some basic topologies that can
happen
because what can happen is if you look
at the least common ancestor of a and d
well that might be something that
separates a and d
from b and c and similarly the least
common ancestor of b and c
that node in the tree might separate
those two nodes from a and d
so the important thing is that you can
actually query
this distance function to determine
which of these quartets
is actually the correct induced topology
on these four different leaves
and it turns out that you can use this
to actually reconstruct the topology of
the tree of life
so now we actually get back to tensor
decompositions this is a little bit of
an aside
but now that we can assume that we know
what the underlying topology of the tree
looks like the basic question we want to
solve is
you know how can we actually construct
these transition matrices
along the trees and it turns out this is
one of the earliest places where
generics algorithm was rediscovered it
was discovered by chang
in the context of mathematical biology
so a bunch of statistics literature
actually i remember
seeing that it all quotes chang's lemma
as being the origin of tensor
decompositions
it turns out that it was known even
before that
and then it turns out that even those
earlier results of lurgan's ross and
abel turn out to be rediscoveries of
a paper of harshman who in turn quotes
generic so it's quite a convoluted story
that
i would need quite a complicated graph
to describe the topology of who
rediscovered what
but in any case what chang's lemma does
is really it
invokes generic's algorithm in a clever
way
so here's the basic idea is that you
know imagine that we know the tree
topology right now
and all we want to do is we want to
reconstruct what are these transition
matrices
along this phylogenetic tree so here's
the beautiful idea about how to apply
generics algorithm
is let's say that we take three
different leads a b
and c what we can do is we can find an
internal node z now in the context of
phylogenic reconstruction this is an
extinct species so we have
no information about it it's a purely
latent variable model we can't figure
out
what the slate and variable model is set
to in our different samples
but now we can do is because we can
re-route the tree arbitrarily
let's imagine that z was now the root of
the tree
because what that means is that we can
now describe paths that go from z to a
and z to b and z to c and the key fact
about these paths that you can see from
this figure
is that these paths don't intersect each
other they're completely
edge disjoint and what this really means
is that you can think about it like a
much simpler diagram where you have
this very simple tree you have a hidden
node z that's your latent variable model
you don't know
what symbol of the alphabet is assigned
in your samples
all you observe are the symbols that are
assigned to a b
and c and there are some stochastic
matrices that describe how you get from
z
to a how you get from z to b and how you
get from z
to c but here's the really important
fact and this is the key to how you use
tensor decompositions
in learning problems is the key fact is
that the joint distribution on a b and c
is very complicated
but the distribution of a b and c are
conditionally independent
if you condition on this latent variable
z
so what i can do is i can sum over all
of the symbols
in this alphabet i sum over all choices
of little sigma
i multiply by this probability that z is
assigned to that symbol in the alphabet
and then i look at a vector right here
which is the conditional distribution of
what the symbol that's assigned to a is
conditioned on z
being assigned to the symbol sigma so if
my entire alphabet
is size k there are k different
possibilities
then this vector of probabilities is a
length k vector
and the important thing is that a is
conditionally independent on b
and c so if you look at the joint
distribution on a b and c
it's actually a rank one tensor once you
condition on z
being equal to sigma because the joint
distribution on a b and c
condition on z equals sigma is the
tensor product of the conditional
distribution on a times the conditional
distribution on b
times the conditional distribution on c
so this is actually the first
aha moment is that you know it sounded
when i first introduced like tensors
tensors it sounded like well here's a
notion of rank that generalizes what
happens for matrices
but where in this in the world would
this come up in problems that i actually
care about
well the truth is that a lot of times
when you're working with nice
probabilistic
generative models you actually do have
some nice conditional independence
structure and that's exactly what
happens here
in phylogenetic reconstruction and in
hidden markov models
is that you have some conditional
dependence on your latent variables
so the important thing here is that if
you think about the way that this
problem is set up
well what i'm describing is the joint
distribution over a b and c
that's a k by k by k tensor and that's
something that i can now
estimate from my data
so i can compute what this tensor is and
then
i can compute its tensor decomposition
and that's unique under pretty general
conditions
you don't need you just need that these
guys are all linearly independent which
happens in a lot of models
and then you can actually uniquely
recover what these conditional
independent distributions are which
actually describe the transition rules
of how you get from z to a
z to b and z to c
so this is a this is a result of muscle
and rock
interestingly i feel like everything in
this literature ends up getting
rediscovered muscle on rock discovered
this in the context of phylogenetic
reconstruction
back in 2006 it turns out you know about
uh eight to ten years later people are
still rediscovering using tensor methods
in much simpler things like learning
hidden markov models which are really
the simpler problem
when you know the underlying tree
structure but you know part of the
reason i wanted to give a tutorial on
this is to try and explain
some of the historical quirks and how at
least i think about the relationship
between these results
so what they showed was that there's a
polynomial time algorithm to learn a
phylogenetic tree now you have to be
careful
because sometimes when you have long
branches you can't really reconstruct
the transition matrices exactly
but what you can do instead is you can
reconstruct other transition matrices
that are statistically indistinguishable
from the ones that you actually want to
learn
and that's how they set up the problem
is what's called path learning
in fact what's kind of neat is that you
can ask questions like well
you know when we think about generics
algorithm we needed this uniqueness we
needed these assumptions on the
underlying factors
that the factors were linearly
independent
now you could wonder do you really need
those kinds of assumptions
to solve these tensor decomposition and
parameter learning kinds of problems
or is it an artifice of the algorithms
that we have for solving these problems
well it turns out that it really is
necessary there's another beautiful
result
contained in the muscle rock paper as it
turns out it's computationally hard
to learn the parameters of even a very
simple general hidden markov model
when your transition matrices are not
full rank
it turns out that it's related to a
problem called noisy parity
which is an infamous problem in in
computational learning theory that
people now use to build crypto systems
based on so this really is hard when you
try and weaken these uniqueness
assumptions that we started off with
and it's part of the reason why some of
the later generalizations in the
psychometrics literature of generics
algorithm
ended up not leading to computationally
efficient algorithms is that they
actually weaken the assumptions you
place on the factors in a way that those
problems might genuinely be
computationally hard
okay so now what i'd like to do is i'd
like to you know take a step back
because i think what's important in all
of this
is to really understand you know what
tensors are
how they arise in high dimensional
learning problems
in particular you know why you're
naturally faced with
low dimensional tensors in learning
problems
and to try and abstract what it is that
makes tensor methods
amenable to those kinds of problems
because if you think about solid genetic
trees and hidden markov models
i claim what's really happening what
makes the thing work why you have a low
rank tensor
is because there's conditional
independence this is what i'll call the
power of conditional independence
if that's the way in which you find a
low rank tensor
within the statistics which you can
compute from your data
so in phylogenetic trees what does this
conditional independence looks like
well it looks like when you have three
different leaves a b and c
those are your extant species you have a
latent variable model that describes an
extinct species and the distribution on
the extant species is conditionally
independent given
the extinct one so hopefully extant
extinct comes
across in my microphone i have a new
microphone so hopefully it's uh
you know not all muddled together let me
tell you
one more simple application of tensor
methods that's one of the beauties of
these
algorithms is that once you have this
tool
you can actually just go around looking
for learning problems figure out
where you have nice conditional
independence properties and just
use tensor decomposition results that's
it it becomes very formulaic and you get
a long list of applications
just from this one generics algorithm
so let me tell you about another problem
i think it's another simple problem
where you can think about
you know how to use sensor structure
that's a problem that's near and dear to
my heart
because i've worked a lot in these kinds
of things it's about learning mixture
models specifically
mixtures of gaussians in fact you make a
kind of strong assumption about the
components of the gaussians in this case
which is you assume that they're all
identical spherical gaussians
so let's imagine that we get samples
from the following generative model
so first we have a high dimensional
gaussian which has a mean
mu and a covariance which is sigma
squared times the identity
now what that means is that all of the
different
directions in the standard axis align
directions are all
independent of each other it's a
spherical gaussian in terms of its shape
and what you do is you create a mixture
model out of these things so you have
not just one gaussian but you have k
gaussians and the way that you sample
from the model is you choose one of the
components at random
with probability proportional to w sub i
that's your mixture model
and then once you've chosen which
component you're sampling from
you just take a sample from the
underlying gaussian
in fact each of these gaussians has a
different mean mu sub i
but they have the same covariance which
is sigma squared
times the identity so just so that we're
all on the same page
this is another example of a latent
variable model
what is the latent variable is that what
i observe
is i observe a high dimensional sample
from this distribution
but i don't know which component
generated
that's the latent variable and it's
again a discrete latent variable
because it just takes on one of k
different values describing which of the
k components the sample came from
so now the basic task here is i want to
take a bunch of samples
and i want to learn the underlying
parameters the w sub i's and the mu sub
i's
let's assume sigma squared is known just
for simplicity not a big deal if it's
not
and i'd like not only a statistically
efficient
method that takes only a polynomial
number of samples to get to some desired
accuracy
but in fact i want my estimator to be
efficiently computable too
it turns out that tensors are a great
way to do that
because we have generics algorithm
so the basic question here is can we
reconstruct the underlying parameters in
polynomial time
so let me tell you a result about of su
and cockaday
which is that there's an algorithm that
works via tensor decomposition
that has polynomial runtime and sample
complexity
and it works just under the conditions
that the mu sub eyes have full rank
and actually that the w sub i's are all
non-zero so these are very same
conditions
now just to be precise um in fact what
happens when you're really close to the
mu
eyes being degenerate well your running
time in your sample complexity blow up
so what really happens is that you
create a matrix whose columns are the mu
sub i's
and you look at the smallest singular
value of that matrix that describes how
far you are from being degenerate
and the running time and the sample
complexity depend on one over sigma min
this was a more sophisticated point so
don't worry about it let's just assume
the mu sub i to full rank and see what
happens
and we won't worry exactly about the
sample complexity issues
but you know these are issues you have
to deal with so here's the main limit in
fact you can reprove the results
just with a couple line proof once you
have generic's algorithm it's very
simple
here's the key lemma this is all that
there is is that it turns out
what you do is there's a tensor that you
know we want
this tensor would it would have a low
rank decomposition
which is which determines the parameters
that we want to learn
so consider this tensor t which is the
sum over i of w sub i that's the scalar
mixing weight
times mu sub i tensor mu sub i tends to
mu sub i
that's an order three sensor it's rank
at most k
now we don't directly have access to
this tensor that would be nice if we did
it turns out that what you can do is you
can compute the first
second and third moment of your
distribution
and you can do that just through samples
and you can construct this tensor t
based on the empirical moments from your
distribution
and then all we'd have to do is we could
apply generics algorithm so
you know the main abstraction is
actually literally the same thing
because the way that we're using tensor
methods
is we're showing that there is a low
rank tensor that we can compute
based on samples from our model whose
tensor decomposition
reveals the parameters we want to learn
and just to emphasize you know
what's really important in this is again
the uniqueness result
behind generic's algorithm because we
need that not only can we compute the
sensor that is low rank whose
ideal low rank decomposition gives us
what we want to learn
we need to know that when we compute any
other low rank tensor decomposition
that we really do get something that
looks like this and learns the
parameters we're after
so that's why uniqueness is important
and that's why
tensors play a key role and solve some
of the
learning problems and identifiability
problems that just having access to a
single matrix like just second moments
of your distribution
sometimes just doesn't cut it
okay so there's a question uh from the
audience let me just answer this live so
am i saying that three tensors is enough
no
no
need to do four tensors or higher great
question so what i'm actually saying is
that for
a bunch of these problems like um
like uh learning mixtures of spherical
galaxies like phylogenetic
reconstruction like hidden markdown
models
third porter tensors work but you're
exactly right you're foreshadowing the
fact that
there's a lot of power to going to
higher order tensors
and in fact there are many more
sophisticated algorithms that i'm not
going to get into here
or in this tutorial that work based on
going to higher order
tensors and there's a lot of value to
doing that because you can handle
more components you can do you can learn
more sophisticated models where you
don't assume
things like spherical gaussians but you
know that's a much more sophisticated
topic so it's a great question but i can
only partially answer it
all right so let's continue so let me
prove this lineup this one is super easy
to prove
right so what am i going to do i'm going
to do the only thing i can do
i'm going to compute the third order
moment for my distribution
okay and so what are the third order
moments well
i look at my random variable x which is
a d
dimensional vector and i look at the af
coordinate in it and i multiplied by the
b of coordinate i multiplied by the c of
course
so i look at the expectation of x of a
times x
b times x sub c nothing complicated
going on here
and if you think about it what's really
going on is you're computing a
third moment tensor which is the
expectation of x
tensor x tensor x that's a d by d by d
tensor
but i'm looking at the entry in that
tensor that's in location
a comma b comma c now the important
thing is that
you can think about a mixture of
spherical gaussians in the following
model
so first you choose a random variable
which describes
which component you're sampling from and
when you choose that component you
really
fix the vector to be mu sub i because
that's the center of that gaussian
and then you add independent noise you
add
a spherical additive gaussian noise to
that component
now the key thing about mixtures of
spherical gaussians with identical
components is that the additive noise
is independent of which of the centers
you choose
so in fact what's really nice is that
when a b and c are distinct
the third moment of your sample of
mixtures of gaussians
look the same as the third moments of
the distribution where you merely sample
the center and add
no noise and of course no noise is a lot
easier
so in fact what it looks like is it
looks like the sum over i of w sub i
times mu i comes from ui tends from ui
that's a d by d by d tensor
and you index into it at the a b and c
location
so if a b and c are distinct that's your
expression so how do you compute this
third order moment and get a
corresponding entry in t which is what
you after
you know they're the same thing
something slightly fancier happens when
you have repeated indices so what if a
equals b
so you're really computing expectation
of x a squared
times x c so you get the same thing
where you
index into this abc entry of this low
rank tensor you wish you had
but there's an extra factor that comes
from the noise this additive sigma
squared noise
so you get a plus sigma squared times
the sum over i of w
sub i mu sub i times c
so this just comes from expressing what
the second moment of a gaussian is you
can just read this off wikipedia and
compute this expression
very simple now the key thing is that
this is not the thing that i
i'm after because it's not the abc entry
in t
but if i know sigma squared then i can
actually remove this extra factor
and subtract off something to correct
the moment so that i really do get the
abc entry of t
because this was really just sigma
squared times the first moment
of the distribution i can compute the
first moment
so the same thing happens when a equal b
equals c
that's just the different correction
terms that's minus three times sigma
squared
times again the first moment and that's
the proof
right so we're actually done this is the
algorithm for learning mixed with
spherical gaussians this is literally
all you need to do
to get the algorithm is in fact you know
you can write the tensor t if you want
this a little bit more compactly what it
actually looks like
is if you look at the third order tensor
and you do this correction term
and there's a nice way to interpret what
the corrections look like
through something called isoleucine
theorem which has to do with
relationships between the moments of
galaxies and matching but you know
whatever
i don't expect you to understand that
but the key point is that now when you
compute this tensor t
you can just use generics algorithm
that's it that's the learning algorithm
so this is the power of conditional
independence we get an algorithm for
learning mixture of spherical gaussians
and
it just works you can also talk about
other generative models other latent
variable models
there's a really nice one that you know
i've also worked on called topic models
where you think about the following type
of generative model
there are some you're observing
documents which themselves are bag of
words which words show up in those
documents and the way that you think
about these
documents as being constructed is that
there's some underlying set of topics
and each topic is a distribution on
words and what you do is
each time you generate a document you
choose one of the topics at random
and then once you've chosen the topic
you sample words from that corresponding
distribution on words and that's your
bag of words that you get
in your document so the important thing
is that topic models also
have great conditional independence
structure what is the conditional
independence as you condition
on the latent variable of what the
hidden topic is
for a given document in fact this even
works with so-called mixed models where
documents are
actually a mixture of topics and they're
things called the latent dirichlet
allocation model and again
you can use tensor methods because the
tensor you construct
is also based on third order moments in
this case it's the joint distribution on
the first three words
in your document you can even do it for
things like community detection
where i won't get into this but it turns
out that you know when
you generate a random graph with a
planted community structure of this
community is better connected within
itself to the rest of the communities
when you do it through something called
the stochastic block model there's a way
to count different graph theoretic
substructures
in this case counting three stars that
actually have nice conditional
independence properties and what the
expected counts are
and then you can again just use
generic's algorithm
in fact it even works for mixed models
with community detection
which are so-called mixed membership
models but
you know i also want to in the last
couple minutes
i uh want to disabuse you of the idea
that
all of this stuff is really well solved
so so far what i did was i went back to
the 1900s and talked about factor
analysis
then i talked about generics algorithm
which got rediscovered many times
and i showed you how it just nails one
by one these different types of latent
variable models
when you have a conditional independent
structure and there's a lot more in this
literature
where the conditional independent
structure takes a lot more tensor
theoretic insights to figure out how to
work with
but what i want to do is i want to give
you a hint of you know actually a whole
world out there where things are
way more complicated where i don't
really have any answers and
you know this is more of an invitation
please solve my problems
so let me tell you about another kind of
latent variable model which is called
orbit retrieval
now something funny is going to happen
in this kind of latent variable model
which is that instead of having the
latent variable models being
discrete like in the case of solution
reconstruction where they're a hidden
symbol
or mixture models whether what component
was used to generate the sample
they're actually going to be continuous
and that's pretty nasty
but the only way that we're going to do
with continuous latent variable models
is when they have a group structure so
what happens if we want to learn the
parameters of a generative model
with a continuous latent variable
let me give you an example so one
example of a problem that fits into the
class of things called orbit retrieval
is imagine that we have a periodic
signal but what happens is that we get
the signal plus noise
but with a random shift where the offset
is chosen uniformly between 0 and 1.
so it's a continuous shift so our latent
variable model is that when we observe a
noisy sample
we don't know what that shift is so it's
a continuous latent variable model
this is a very important problem in
signal processing
there's something called global
registration where you get
noisy pictures of a two-dimensional
image
but now what you don't know is the
rotation within
so2 these are noisy pictures of alan
turin
and we don't know what the group element
of so2 is that describes how we've
rotated the picture of alan turing
and in fact these problems go pretty
deep into
really the you know some of the
fundamental areas in the sciences and
engineering
where they've been major discoveries
with tons of nobel prizes
one of my favorite examples is what's
called cryo-em microscopy
where we wanna determine a 3d molecular
structure from random 2d
noisy projections and here the
underlying thing is that i have a 3d
structure i want to reconstruct
but i don't actually know what rotation
in fo3 it is
so the way that you formulate orbit
retrieval problems is that
there's an underlying group and a group
action and there's an underlying signal
that you want to recover x
so what happens is each sample looks
like you choose a random element of your
group
from the har measure you apply that
group action
on x and then you add noise let's say
gaussian noise
and the question is that you want to
recover the underlying vector x
now you can't actually tell the
difference in x and anything else in its
orbit
so instead what you want to do is you
want to recover some x hat that's close
to the orbit
that's why it's called orbit retrieval
and so this leads to something that i
call orbit
tensor decomposition because in this
case what you can do is you can do the
usual thing
you take samples from your model and you
compute the moments
now the moments also have a tensor
structure
but the difference is that it's not a
discrete sum
over some discrete latent variable
instead it's an integral
over this continuous group because it
looks like rho of g
times you know action on x tensor to the
third power
so the question is can you recover x up
to its orbit
from a tensor that looks like this now
it's kind of problematic because t
is actually not low rank you actually
have to use
the algebraic and group theoretic
relationship between the different
factors in order to solve the
decomposition problem
let me tell you a baby result this is
all that i know
is there's a polynomial time algorithm
that works when x is random
when you have the continuous group so2
but really there are many bigger
problems out there like what happens for
non-abelian groups well
you know the truth is we probably need
some representation theory and this is a
bit beyond my
knowledge of clutch coordinate
coefficients i'll give you just a little
baby hint in the last one or two minutes
about
what goes into this algorithm is that
there are different ways you can think
about working with sensors
there's a beautiful way called tensor
networks which are graphical
representations for tensors
and operations on them so you think
about a tensor like this little diagram
on the left there's just the t
sitting in the middle and there are
three legs and there are three legs
because you have to index in with three
different choices of you know
one of i one of j one of k to figure out
what the corresponding entry of t is
now the important thing is you can
manipulate these diagrams
as a proxy for doing tensor
manipulations
so when you take two different third
order tensors and you connect them along
some leg
well the resulting thing you look at has
four different legs outgoing so it looks
like a fourth order tensor
and in fact what you're doing or you're
supposed to be doing is you're supposed
to be
summing you're supposed to associating i
and i in these tensors t and u
and then summing over it to get a fourth
order tensor that's indexed by a b
c and d but now the cool thing is that
you can actually build a lot of
beautiful algorithms from simple tensor
networks
in fact in the existing literature that
does a lot of things with tensor methods
for all kinds of latent variable models
a lot of times these are implicit within
their work
is that the way that they're using
spectral methods is they're really
building them from tensor networks but
it turns out that you can define a
general blueprint for how to use a
tensor network if i give you a tensor t
you use this tensor network to create a
new meta sensor
and then you flatten it somehow into a
matrix kind of like the way that we
flattened to get
generic's algorithm and then you do
something like spectral you compute the
leading eigenvector
but what you can prove is that a lot of
times that actually recovers the
underlying
x that you want so what's kind of crazy
is that we tried this framework of you
know how do we get orbit tensor
decomposition
for this case of so2 and this was the
blueprint we came up with it's a
spectral method that's so ugly you would
never write it out if you had to write
out all of these indices by hand and
explain this formula
but this is the blueprint and kind of
amazingly you can show that this is
literally the
smallest test tensor network that will
work for this problem
so there's a whole rich world out there
about how exactly to use tensors now
in the context of having group structure
all right so at the beginning i didn't
really give you an outline of what i'm
going to talk about in this tutorial
but part one was about some of the bread
and butter of how do you do high
dimensional learning
and one of the most powerful tools we
have are tensor decompositions and their
uniqueness that paves the way for
applying them for latent variable models
what i'll talk about next time are
algorithms for robust estimation and
these are unsupervised learning problems
where we're going to start the t's apart
you know how do you get provably robust
and computationally efficient
algorithms even in cases where
your moments don't actually have a nice
tensor structure
what happens if an adversary is
corrupting 10 of your data
it turns out there's still a lot you can
do algorithmically
then i'll talk about the difficulty of
supervised learning in the context of
noise
because there it turns out that there's
an interesting chicken and egg problem
of finding the right noise model that's
both
reasonable and lends itself to
algorithms rather than computational
attractability
i'll pontificate wildly on you know what
these things might have to do with
algorithmic fairness
because it's interesting to me that um
you know that
a lot of problems in algorithmic
fairness seem to be you could frame them
as you know learning problems in in some
regimes so
i think there might be more to do there
and in the last part i'm going to go
really
uh you know outside the box and i'm
going to say that you know actually
latent variable models are much more
general than we give them credit for
there's a sense in which inverse
problems you want to solve in the
sciences
that you need to do in order to answer
scientific questions
like you know is this thing i'm
observing in the sky a double star a
single star
well you can think about those inverse
problems as a type
of latent variable model for which a lot
of the techniques that i'll be
describing
will actually have some interesting
things to say
so i'll stop there and see you next time
all right thanks so much anker for that
uh great talk
i think we have time for a couple of
questions if if people want to ask
[Music]
um
maybe i can ask a question so generic's
algorithm
the tensor has to be a rank at most n i
guess where
is there some simple modification of it
that does well for
slightly above n
no that's a great question so
i mean it's there are a few different
answers for this i think
so first you can do something at a very
extreme end which is
uh you know let's say you have a third
order tensor and the factors
x aren't merely generic but they're
actually random
then you can do way better because you
can actually recover the underlying
factors through
sum of squares and other kinds of
methods up to end of the three halves
now what's kind of wacky is that you
know under generic
assumptions not actually random x you
know these tensors are unique
up to about n squared and
uh we can't get anywhere close to n
squared in fact chryskal's uniqueness
theorem the important thing is that it
would work
up to three halves times n
but it's not known computationally how
to actually solve
you know the corresponding algorithmic
problem underneath kryskal's uniqueness
theorem
so in the case where you have generic
tensors nothing is
yet known about how to go above n in
fact what's kind of a killer
is that you can think about methods in
algebraic circuit complexity
that you know there's a beautiful result
of ron roz that if you can construct
explicit third order tensors of
uh rank little omega of n then you would
get the first super linear circuit lower
counts
now unfortunately that tells you you
know some of the difficulties about
trying to get
algorithms that you know work
generically beyond n like n log n
is that how how are you going to
actually certify what their rank is
you know when you go up to n log in
without accidentally proving some
pretty earth-shattering results in
circuit complexity
in fact what's a little bit worse is
that people have been talking about
algebraic obstructions
to the methods that we have like the
method of shifted partial derivatives
and algebraic circuit complexity
these turn out to give you no go
theorems for getting beyond eight
n with different types of formulations
uh for third order tensor decompositions
but then again the answer your question
is morally kind of yes because there's
something trivial i can do
which is i could take a fifth order
tensor and i could massage it into an
n squared by n squared by n tensor
and then generically you're going to
have linear independence even up to rank
n squared so that
you can actually start to study through
models of like smooth analysis and study
their stability and people do that
uh i've done that uh it turns out that
you can even do a little bit better
which is for fourth order tensors
there's actually
an electrical engineering community that
has to do with independent component
analysis that has uniqueness theorems
that work up to n squared
so there's sort of a very interesting
you know relationship between what you
can and can't do
but if you think about learning context
you know what it costs you to work with
lower order tensors
is merely what it costs you to work with
higher order tensors is that you
take more samples in order to reasonably
estimate the entries
and so for example for orbit tensor
decomposition
take the order of the tensor to be a
hundred it should make the problem a lot
easier
i don't know anything
any more questions
are there questions on the q a oh okay
sorry uh let me just answer
live some of the questions that are
asked in the q a
so there's a great question from holden
lee how robust is generic's algorithm to
noise
so what really plays the key role here
is robustness
to noise of it of an eigen decomposition
so it turns out that this will be robust
in always provided that the eigenvalues
are separated from each other
and that the actual matrix that you use
to diagonalize it
is well conditioned so in my book which
is
linked to on the simon's website i think
there is a noise stability analysis
there but unfortunately i don't actually
know of earlier noise stability analyses
some of the first applications
of tensor methods and learning problems
didn't actually use the phrase generic
algorithm so they actually invented
their own versions of noise stability
analysis
for their particular problems at hand
but it is
stable under fairly reasonable
conditions
and is there any connection between
tensor decomposition
and deep learning
um sort of so there's a bunch of work
that teng you mon collaborators have
where you think about
um you know even depth two nets
thinking about the joint distribution
you observe on the output
and you can think about the sense in
which it's approximately low rank
this also shows up even in situations
where you have like
directed graphical models but i can't
say too much more
about that because it's very technically
complicated and i don't know
okay uh so i i actually am having some
technical difficulties and i can't see
questions in the q a but i assume there
aren't
any more of those so
thanks again ankur for the fantastic
talk looking forward to the installment
tomorrow and let's uh
take a break in the gather town until
noon when we'll have another talk from
jelani